hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
reviewing the trailer today for Magic
Mike double X I wonder what the audience
retention rate on this video is gonna be
so yeah I just literally finished Magic
Mike this morning I really dug the film
I loved the cinematography I loved the
way it was just shot they let the camera
just go on was like watching life this
whole time and then they don't know this
is a spoiler if you haven't seen Magic
Mike they don't know how to note Magic
Mike witting stripping and saying he's
gonna embark on a new adventure I'm not
sure how this sequel would really play
out but I'm interested to see like what
kind of Part two they do I know it's
directed not by Steven Soderbergh but a
guy who's been like an ad on a lot of
his movies so I'm sure this might have
like a good-enough similar tone and plus
I'm not gay
like [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of these guys
that's a good tease maybe it's just not
really showing you what it's about but
it's establishing that he's coming back
[ __ ] man I wish I could move like him
he's just so [ __ ] sexy like there are
a few men in this world that I will put
my penis in and he is one of them you
know I got a bit like the stripping
scenes are really entertaining this one
seems a little bit more glamorized like
it kind of reminded me of Entourage in a
way it has Channing Tatum and a bunch of
girls new muscles LLC from True Blood
returning I hope you get a clearer shot
of his dick this time something tells me
the tone of this one's gonna be faster
paced it's not gonna take its time as
much because you know Magic Mike it's a
pretty fast paced movie but because
there's not a lot of cuts for the scenes
it actually makes it feel a little bit
longer than what it is this one seems
like it's gonna have a little bit more
editing to it it's kind of weird when I
thought of step up for a second but how
can you sort of not it kind of look like
step up for a moment yeah like I don't
care or like oh it's the first one on my
girlfriend [ __ ] sexy in its own way
like at first I was like let's do you
peel the male strippers but then after a
while I was like you know what this is a
pretty interesting world I like how in
this world there's no judgement of the
characters from the writer or director
it's just portraying as life I thought
there's gonna be a lot more dancing the
cinematography looks very similar and I
think they know this guy he's pretty
much been mentored by Steven Soderbergh
so I'm sure he's gonna do a great job
there's books like fifty Shades of Grey
that talk about the perfect man that
doesn't exist but I think Channing Tatum
is the perfect man anyway guys if you
needed the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and let's do shadow
Iman fear on mr. Ryan Wright I would
love to give a shout out to your channel
is super [ __ ] awesome I watch it all
the time and also do a reaction video of
three hotties on your channel a list of
Veronica and Sally you three are [ __ ]
gorgeous
Veronica is the best-looking one just
gonna put that out there seeing them on
your channel makes watching your videos
a hundred times better well you can
masturbate while they watch the videos
even - Veronica don't tell her I said
that keep the great videos coming see
you mmm
ing Iman Fearon you sound like a great
dude you know I really appreciate the
love I appreciate the support you keep
watching this channel and you know what
Matt you might get a frontal view one
day you keep it up
I might just send you a dick pic